the coronavirus of course is a global
problem a global challenge and fears of
a second wave of infections has led some
countries to rethink their reopening
plans Russia now has the second highest
number of reported cases behind the US
and the Chinese city where the pandemic
began plans to test every single person
to guard against a recurrence Asia
correspondent Ramey Inocencio has that
story
Luhan on alert again in the next 10 days
China's coronavirus epicenter is testing
its entire population of 11 million
people
Wuhan reported six new coronavirus cases
over the weekend the first since the
city celebrated the lifting of its 76
day lockdown in April in South Korea
Seoul has ordered more than 2,000 clubs
and bars closed
and now contact tracing nearly 11,000
people a new cluster of more than 100
kovat 19 cases were found linked to the
Capitals entertainment district of
Itaewon dr. drum kim is a leading
epidemiologist in south korea the
government of korea hadn't done this
then there would be hundred 19 people
out there infecting other people and so
that has actually really gets to the
point of tracing people and in Russia
tragedy on top of infections a fire at a
hospital in saint-petersburg killed at
least four coronavirus patients and the
pandemic had close to President Vladimir
Putin his spokesperson Dmitry Peskov is
just the latest high-ranking official to
fall ill but in Japan some good news
Prime Minister Shinzo Abe a says the
country is now on a steady path to
ending its epidemic the national state
of emergency could be lifted across much
of the country Thursday for CBS this
morning
ramie Inocencio Tokyo